a Las Vegas teenager once named a star  graduate faces charges connected to the  shooting of a young man and the  threatening of a young woman in a North  Las Vegas Park seventeen-year-old Emilio  Roca is Accused in the November shooting  police arresting him late last month the  young woman telling police she knew Roca  and had a pair of his airpods wireless  headphones which may have allowed him to  track her location she told police she  and the shooting victim were in the park  when Roka approached them saying who the  f are you before he allegedly shot the  victim officers say Roca also pointed a  gun at that young woman saying I will  kill you too in 2021 roca's High School  named him a star graduate writing Emilio  is a student leader who is always  willing to help others he also serves as  a role model not only for other students  but also for his family